من الدوحه مفرد العربيه ليس بازاري الذي
يتابع كل هذه المباريات والاجواء ليث اهلا
وسهلا بك كيف هي الاجواء من عندك وابرز
التوقعات لمباريات الليله لنبدا بمباراه
البرازيل وسويسرا
لاعب البرازيلي سويسرا اليوم وبعد اقل من
ساعه ونصف الساعه من الان طالب وكمان
نشاهد طبعا هناك الحشود الجماهير العربيه
الارجنتينيه البرازيليه وغيرها طبعا
المباراه وتونسيه طبعا بس المباراه راح
تكون في استديو
974 هنا في قطر بعد ساعه ونصف الساعه من
الان من البرازيل وسويسرا عندنا ماريو
قديمه هنا الى الى الدوحه لمتابعه
المباريات منذ يومين سبورت
لحضور لحضور المباراه ويفضلون دائما ان
يكونوا اتفضل قرب ههه
بحبوا يكونوا يتابعوا الاحتفالات التي
تقام ما بعد المباراه طبعا عندنا برده
فريق تونس
كثير واقفين معنا وباستنوا
اكلنا عن المنتخب التونسي
[موسيقى]
طبعا طالب الاجواء هنا اذا اخذنا الصوره
بنشوف همم بالمكان هون كثير يعني حضرتك
[تصفيق]
همم اذا شفنا في شخص جاي من اليمن اصلا هو
اصلا من اليمن وعايش كندا ولابس المنتخب
الارجنتيني انت ليش الارجنتين ميسي وينه
وين الشباب السعوديين عنك ما شافوك ههه
انت صاحبي كمان ان شاء الله باذن الله مع
المكسيك باذن الله نعوضها باذن الله
عن طالب يعني اليوم زرنا صباحا مكان اقامه
المنتخب المكسيكي الذي تناول وجبه غداء
همم السعوديه الجريش والعيش والكبيس كمان
اكلوا اليوم الظهر كانوا حابين نتعرفوا
على الماكولات العربيه خصوصا السعوديه
حضرتك من وين تعال حضرتك من السعوديه
للمنتخب السعودي
احنا السعوديه بالنسبه لنا السعودي فوق
فوق طيب المنتخب
ههه
مين بيروح نعم طيب هذه الاجواء طالب اذا
شفنا بعمق السوره اذا امكن ناخذ الصوره بس
مبين هناك جماهير كثيره يعني هناك شخص
يحمل كاميرا همم يلبس الزي البرازي
البرازيلي من وين حضرتك من العراق من
العراق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تلاقينا الينا هذه الاجواء سنكون معك في
نشرات لاحقه لمتابعه مجريات هذه المباريات